okay uh that microphone yeah this one
either one zero
wait can you hear us
yeah i can hear you can you say
something so that we can hear you
can you hear me
online people can hear me
coming through your too
can you hear me now
yoga are you
suggesting wait can you speak one more
time yeah yeah
sorry we're having trouble hearing you
in the auditorium
give me one moment please
yeah
how many of you will also be hearing
through the spring most of you right
we've been already planning the spring
spring program on
learning and games
and everything you've been talking about
is highly relevant there in the game
setting robustness is key non-diversity
issues happen all over the place
all kinds of dynamical systems issues
and uh
so it's great to see applications to
neural nets that's kind of a great
prediction it's a thing but prediction
and games going together it's really i
think you know much richer
because we can't trust the data there
may be an adversary wants to mess up the
auction you know
when you're doing it classically you
just assume those things away more or
less
but if you have data coming in and
they're coming from real people you
can't assume they're way anymore
so the real world problem demand should
be robust even much more so than neural
nets
because you know there's gonna be an
adversary almost by definition
so i'm excited how that program is gonna
go i think some some real new ideas will
come out of that
and of course the classical literature
was very convex now you know can you try
again
duality et cetera et cetera and the
modern problems are not convex anymore
it's where a whole group of us are
trying to both explore and exploit a set
of options
if we're all by ourselves at the
abandoned problem i guess we're a little
bit and exploit a lot
but if i can watch the rest of you too i
hope you will also explore
but if you're watching me you're
probably not going to want to explore
you're going to free rock
all right so it's our way to incentivize
each of us
so you can't and it's a clever way to do
it there's uh yeah martina if you want
to try talking
without a problem i know yeah it's just
coming through the auditorium it's not
it's not coming in
a slippery way that you can get a
central person to have each of the group
do a little exploration they'll hold
your profits
that's next week's lecture
the decision person gets to know all
about the date of all the others
you need to think you know absolutely
that's right
the output can be able to party
computation but also kind of effectively
what you have to do is solve it
and you can get real results
literally they're
okay so it's a local problem here in the
room
um
there's not just a button to
press somewhere
[Music]
if you were to bring yours up here and
connect with them
okay
hello do you hear me wait who
yeah i can't hear you can you hear me
you're here
you hear me
yes i can hear you
can you hear me um
no
i've also lost control of my ability to
yeah that should turn that on because i
guess you hooked me up
right so where's your
make sure these are up
let's try that again
hello
displayport
wait can you hear can you talk now
yeah uh hello
hello
let's try it
so you guys can't hear me felipe go lay
do you hear me
philippe hears me
i can't hear you i'm on zoom
way who don't you hear me i can't hear
you
he's saying he can hear you but it's not
coming through
do you hear me say yes or no
way who hears me but his is not coming
through this is not coming into here
it's coming through
if you unplug and just put the volume up
can we can we just hear it if we stick
unfortunately because he's put this
thing in here
maybe just unplug okay all right
let's try that
um
okay let me just put the volume up good
good point
all right
hello
hello
can you hear me okay
okay do you hear us now way
yes
i think we've yeah we
he got the feedback loop closed okay so
you're now you can give your talk we're
going to hold a microphone up in front
of my computer which is uh
about the best we got here but i think
that'll work okay uh so do you hear me
okay
yeah i hear you okay does the people
hear you in the room
okay you can go go
okay okay
good uh sorry that i cannot come to the
campus today but i am physically in
berkeley so uh today i'm gonna talk
about implicit regularization in deep
learning
so let me just start by briefly uh
reviewing the pipeline of deep learning
so usually we first need to have a data
set so for example imagenet is the one
of the most popular
and then we need to design a model and
in the context of deploying the model is
usually in the form of a deep neural
network and there are usually many many
parameters in the model and we want to
find a configuration of these parameters
such that the model can perform well on
the data population and the way to find
such parameters is to try to minimize
some loss function some training loss
function which basically measures how
well the model performs on the training
data set and in practice the loss is
usually minimized by the gradient design
algorithm or some variants of the
gradient descent algorithm and this
pipeline has achieved tremendous success
in practice
which is very mysterious from a
theoretical perspective
and one of the biggest mystery is
one of the biggest mysteries in the
theory of deep learning is the so-called
generalization mystery that is over
parametrized neural networks can
generalize well meaning that they not
only can fit the training samples but
also perform well um unseen test samples
so so let me use a simple example to
illustrate this uh let's say this this
is our training data set with images of
cats and dogs and when we train a neural
net to classify these data sets the
neural net could learn this blue
boundary for example
but because the the model is usually
highly over parameterized it is also
capable of representing very complicated
functions uh for example this red
boundary which looks very different from
the blue one but these two solutions
perform equally well on the training
data set so they both have zero training
arrow but they may perform very
differently on new test samples because
these two are very different functions
that means even if we successfully solve
the optimization problem and get small
training arrow that doesn't imply we
will have generalization we will have
small test errors because in principle
we don't know whether we found the blue
solution or the real solution
if we just look at the training training
arrow but in practice
just by minimizing the training loss
using gradient descent-like algorithms
we can somehow often find solutions that
generalize well to test samples and this
is the the mystery that's not well
understood
and what is believed to be an
explanation of this behavior
is that there's an implicit
regularization effect from the
optimization algorithms we use
the main proposal is that the
optimization algorithms such as gradient
descent or stochastic gradient descent
prefers low complexity solutions so even
if the whole model space is very complex
gradient design will only find certain
low complexity solutions for some reason
and that if that's true that would imply
a good generalization performance
so i'm gonna present two uh simple deep
learning examples where we are able to
mathematically characterize the implicit
organization going on there so the first
one is for linear networks and the
second is for non-linear networks
so let me uh go into the first example
so for for this example we will consider
this classical problem of matrix
completion so the goal of measures
completion is to recover a low rank
matrix given only a subset of its
entries
and this is a well-stated problem in
machine learning and statistics and the
typical application is in recommendation
systems so think about predicting user
ratings but given only a subset of the
ratings so today for simplicity we'll
just assume that
this ground choose matrix which i call m
is a square matrix so it's a d by d
matrix and it it has low rank
so
so how do you solve this problem the
first we can easily write down a naive
training loss which looks like this but
we try to find a matrix w uh which is
our model that minimizes this training
loss over the observed entries
and of course many optima exists for
this problem because we can just assign
any values to the unobserved entries so
there's no hope of recovering the true
matrix m using this naive approach but
that's simply because we haven't used
the assumption that the matrix should be
low rank so we may want to add some uh
explicit regularization uh to encourage
low rank and the classic approach is to
add a nuclear norm regularization like
this so recall that nuclear norm is the
sum of all the singular values of a
matrix which can be viewed as a convex
relaxation of the rank
but what we are considering today is a
different and a counter-intuitive
approach which i call a deep learning
approach so what we do here is to try to
find this matrix m as a product of
multiple matrices and in the language of
deep learning uh this can be viewed as a
deep linear network because it's
parameterized as a product of l matrices
w1 through wl which is a composition of
l layers of linear transformations so
here's the objective function
corresponding to this approach
and so it's a function of this l
matrices w1 through wl and notice that
here uh i'm i'm requiring all these
matrices to have to be size d by d so we
are by doing this we are not imposing
any constraint on the rank of the matrix
and actually it's very easy to see that
this problem is exactly the same as the
problem in this naive method because we
can still express all the d by d
matrices using the product of multiple d
d matrices so it seems that doing this
reprimatization doesn't make much sense
and we wouldn't expect this to be useful
at all
but the but the surprise is that
empirically if we just minimize this new
objective using gradient descent with
initialization close to zero we can
uh we can almost always recover the
ground choose matrix and accuracy
and this is surprising because we are
not explicitly asking for a low rank
solution in the objective
uh so the only possibility is that the
optimization algorithm we use which is
gradient descent in this case has an
implicit requiration that somehow can
help us find the low rank branches
matrix
and this implicit regression effect we
can understand it uh by analyzing the
dynamics of the gradient descent
algorithm in this problem and an
important step in the analysis is to
derive the dynamics of the singular
values of the solution matrix which is
this equation and from this equation we
can see that the depth the number of
layers l affects this dynamics via this
blue factor and we can interpret it as
inducing a rich get richer phenomenon
among different singular values which
encourages low rank because different
singular values will grow at very
different rates according to this
equation and we can verify this
intuition by plotting the evolution of
all the singular values during the
course of gradient descent
okay so basically for this problem we
had an a very nice mental picture of how
the gradient descent algorithm prefers
low complexity solutions and the
appropriate notion of complexity here is
the rank of the solution matrix and and
we can divide the space of all the
solutions according to their rank
and our grant use matrix might be here
which is a low rank global minimum of
the loss function but there are also
many other global minima which have
higher rent and they all have zero
training loss
but so what happens when we run variant
descent starting close to zero is that
it will search first search over the
rank 1 spaces
and then the rank 2 rank 3 and
eventually it will settle down at a low
rank minimum so it will never reach
these higher rank spaces so it won't go
to all those non-generalizable minima
and this is done implicitly by running
gradient descent
so we can view this dynamic picture uh
us indicating a more general statement
that uh maybe neural network learns
functions of increasing complexity
during training and the notion of the
complexity in this example was the rank
of the matrix and and this general
hypothesis is to believe to be perhaps
true
in some sense but in general we still
don't know what is the right way to
characterize the complexity of neural
networks and especially in nonlinear
deep neural networks this becomes much
more challenging than linear networks
so and next i'm going to very briefly
talk about another interesting
theoretical result along the lines of
this general hypothesis and in
particular we will show that in some
natural settings a non-linear network
trained by gradient descent only learns
a linear function first before it starts
to learn anything else
and so the formal result is for a
standard two-layer neural network and
migration descent so the network looks
like this so it has two layers and
there's non-linearity in the hidden
layer of the network
and we also consider a hypothetical
process which is the linear model also
trained by gradient descent so
so it's just a simple linear model on
the input x so the beta 1 and beta 2
here are the parameters in this linear
model
and what we prove uh is that these two
processes can be coupled and
specifically in the early time of
running gradient descent the neural
network and the linear model compute
almost the same function for input x
coming from the underlying data
distribution
so that means also the neural network
has non-linear capacity
uh if we but if when we are running
gradient descent it will implicitly bias
the neural network towards a simple
linear function at the beginning of of
training so this is also a very
interesting implicit regulation effect
so here are some experiments to to
verify these results so basically these
plots are showing that uh the neural
network uh and the hypothetical linear
model basically behave the same in the
in the early time of gradient descent
which verifies uh this theorem
okay so so to to conclude uh i argued
that uh the implicit regulation effect
from the optimization algorithms is key
to understanding the generalization
behavior in modern deep learning and i
presented two case studies where we are
able to show that uh show exactly how
neural network learns functions of
increasing complexity during the course
of gradient descent and these examples
also show that
perhaps analyzing the dynamics of the
learning procedure may be important to
understand or even just to describe the
implicit requisition effect in deep
learning
okay that's the end of my talk and feel
free to get in touch if you are
interested in chatting about deep
learning thanks
[Music]
we'll move to my notice now so i'll just
send a chat
i'm a knowledge do you hear me
[Music]
yep i can hear you can you hear me yes